ça manque de sincérité un peu tout ça
c'était une supercherie macron
aujourd'hui qu'elle se voit tous les
jours aujourd'hui il s'allie l'histoire
de france macro et dans la séduction il
est pas dans la conviction donc c'est il
est entouré d'énarques et donc son
projet ils varient selon les marques qui
parle le dernier le président ne connaît
pas les français ça fait sont traités
les sujets sa façon très technocratique
d'aborder les choses sa manière d'en
rajouter pour créer des images
d'empathie on peut être élu président de
la république et pas connaître les
français c'est un transgressif ils
transgressent me l'avait tuée elle celui
qui l'a fait françois hollande c'est
celui qui a fait emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron il a contribué
étroitement à la politique de françois
alors je peux comprendre qu humainement
ces transgressions à répétition sont des
transgressions qui sont qui sont
gênantes payet volonté claire du
gouvernement d'affaiblir le parlement il
ya une volonté claire de concentration
des pouvoirs à l'elysée où beaucoup de
réformes de toutes natures et une bonne
partie de ces réformes n'a pas été
engagé par le gouvernement aujourd'hui
macro et dit jamais qu'il est de gauche
enfin il a entouré d'experts de gaulle
de fonctionnaires de gauche la plupart
des politiques sont de gauche bon bref
il est de gauche la majorité est une
majorité de gauche si une majorité
socialiste j'ai rarement entendu un
président aussi floue sur tout mais
terriblement flou sur la manière de
financer les annonces qu'il a eue hier
au fur et à mesure du temps égrainant ça
manque de sincérité un peu tout ça c'est
un manque de sincérité
un peu